In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful, this is Omar Mohsen. I told
you today a beautiful program that will help you very much in the matter of
taking pictures and not greatly reducing the quality, and at the
same time you can put
your rights or your logo on
the picture. Let us together quickly create the
program and its link, God willing, it will be.  It
is in the description of the video
after I used
ours, and then he appears to me and tells me I want
the language you are using, but unfortunately
he is using the language of the device, so it will be in Arabic. We do ok and then we do it. He tells me, “Hot, let us
focus together on the topic.”
Any program because it makes a lot of difference with us. He
tells me that he will go to this place. We will
tell him. He tells me that he will go here in his shorts. He says to me, “Do you want anything
more?” We say to him, “Oh, I
want to put a T-shirt on my desktop and do Next.”
After that, Install. I will notice that he has finished
Install.  It appears on my desktop. After I
open the program, I find it in
Arabic. It then takes me to
the folder for my photos.
I want to make it smaller, and I will tell it to Open OK. It will tell
me the first thing you want the
resolution of these photos to be. I will leave them as
default, even if I want accuracy.  I can
specify from here, and in the same situation, I specify as it
says its sorting or its quality is the best
or the lowest. At the same time, there is a
certain percentage here. I prefer to leave everything as it is and
reduce, but I set the percentage and make it 70%. For example, the format of the
image remains what type it is.  Also,
leave it as it is.
Everything, leave it as it is, and enter the subject of the
watermark or my chord mark, or
the logo
marked on the watermark. This place will appear to me. He told me, “Give the
place your logo.” I,
for example, put my logo here. I
will tell him, of course, without a background, in PNG format.  He
uses Photoshop and tells me to tell me where it
will be suitable for you to put it. For example, I will leave it
in the part below here and I will not do anything else.
And I will do it. He will say, “Where do you want to put your thing?” I tell him, “I want to put it on the
disktop.
Of course, I
can save this as the default settings.”  Any pictures
I put and do well, it will start to
reduce the pictures and at the same time put the logo on them.
After I finish, the words that
we see in front of us will appear to me. I start opening the pictures and I will
notice that the picture is smaller in area or the
logo is underneath. Of course I treated the logo in a way that it might not be a little
clear.
Okay, let’s compare.  This is the original and we can see what
the differences are between them. We
put all the pictures next to each other and see what the
pictures are to check the spaces.
I will notice that picture number five was 178 and now
108. I can see what the difference is between them.
But the differences, as we see, are in
very simple things. A
difference, but almost things that cannot be seen as they are.  We are two
pictures, there is no difference. This
was an explanation with you today. If anyone has any
new ideas or has a new program and would like
to explain it or sees that it will benefit others, please share it. Thank
you and I am sorry if it took a long time.
Don’t forget to like and share the channel so that everyone
can benefit.